fue la primera visita de una experta de
la ONU en guantánamo denuncia entre
otras cosas el aislamiento de los
detenidos la vigilancia casi constante
la falta de asistencia sanitaria y de
acceso a la justicia
el informe expone detalladamente como
esta arbitrariedad provoca una profunda
inseguridad sufrimiento y ansiedad a
todos los detenidos sin excepción
observe que tras dos décadas de custodia
el sufrimiento de los detenidos es
profundo y continúa
pero para la relatora especial de la ONU
lo más preocupante es la imposibilidad
de superar el trauma de la tortura que
los prisioneros han sufrido Every todos
y cada uno de los detenidos con los que
me reuníven con los daños implacables
que se derivan de las prácticas
sistemáticas de entrega tortura y
detención arbitraria
el centro de detención de guantánamo fue
creado respuesta a los atentados del 11
de septiembre de 2001 se eligió
encarcelar a los detenidos en Cuba para
poder privarlos de la protección
constitucional estadounidense en total
cerca de 800 personas han sido detenidas
allí y casi ninguna ha sido juzgada por
la justicia varios presidentes han
prometido cerrar la cárcel como Barack
Obama oyon pero todavía sin éxito pues
depende de la aprobación de la Corte
Suprema de Justicia y del Congreso
Es cierto que nunca logré cerrar esta
cosa debido a las restricciones
que nos impone el congreso
la experta se felicitó de la decisión de
Estados Unidos de permitirle ingresar en
el centro de guantánamo pidió el cierre
de la cárcel y llamó Estados Unidos a
proporcionar disculpas y garantías de no
repetición urgentemente